sometimes the world feels hmm
boring we visited all the remote islands
conquered the arctic and penetrated the
deepest jungles
but there is still one place to explore
it's a wet
and deadly desert inhabited by
mysterious creatures
living in total darkness the deep sea
let's dive down
[Music]
when we look at the sheer scale of the
earth's oceans
it's hard to believe that less than two
percent of all biomass on earth
lives here and of that small percentage
around 90 percent is located close to
the surface
in the first 200 meters this
is where we begin our journey here
light can still penetrate the water
which allows photosynthesis to occur
phytoplankton trillions and trillions of
single-celled algae and bacteria
make up the foundation of the ocean's
ecosystem
and they're consumed by bigger plankton
who are consumed by other species
the sea floor at this depth is akin to
the amazon rainforest
and is often covered with coral reefs
algae and other sea plants
that are home to a plethora of sea
animals
so far we've focused most of our
attention on this comparatively pleasant
environment
where we fish swim pollute and do
science so let's dive deeper
moving from familiar coastal waters into
deeper more remote waters
we eventually reach the edge of the
continental shelf
where we're confronted with the
continental slope the long descent
down to the deep sea with every
additional meter of water
light fades drastically which means
there are basically no more plants
and the seemingly steep continental
slope begins to remind us of the surface
of the moon
looking out we're faced by what seems to
be endless open water
let's leave the slope behind us and
enter what's known as the twilight zone
the portal to the deep sea as we sink
down
further the water pressure rises to
deadly levels
the deepest scuba dive ever came in at
332 meters
at that depth the pressure is like
having 200 cars
stacked on top of you yet we've only
completed
three percent of our journey while this
region
seems pretty grim many fish and other
animals actually spend at least half
their lives down here
during the day it's a good place to rest
and recover
hidden from predators in the vast dark
waters
at night they can travel more safely
into shallower zones to feed in the food
rich surface waters
in this transition zone between twilight
and darkness
light becomes a powerful tool
over 90 percent of the species
indigenous to this deep environment
use bioluminescence chemicals to create
light
they do so as camouflage against the
very faint sunlight
to send signals to potential mates or to
confuse and scare attackers
or they use light to hunt
another tool for survival in the dark is
teamwork
at around 700 meters we encounter a
colony of siphonophores
they can be up to 50 meters in length
but are only as wide as a broomstick
to attract prey a colony creates a
tragically beautiful bright blue or red
light
and deploys a curtain of tentacles
filled with toxic needles
that kill anything that comes too close
but most species living down here have
to rely on an
unlikely resource marine snow
white flaky stuff that constantly sinks
from the surface to the bottom of the
ocean
it consists of dead plant or animal
parts fecal matter
shells sand or dust even though this
doesn't sound very tasty
without this crucial resource life in
the deep sea would starve it's in this
area that the most fascinating battles
between two
unlikely enemies could happen sperm
whales hunt
and attack giant squid the size of a
house
while the squid fight back ferociously
they probably don't stand
a chance but they do leave permanent
marks on their killer skin
as we reach 1000 meters deeper than the
tallest structure built by humans
we need to be careful this is the
midnight zone
a place of utter darkness
a barely explored wet wasteland
consisting of nothing but endless black
open water
at these depths it's harder for a human
to take a swim
than to take a walk in space
finding food down here is really hard so
life had to adapt
and become extremely energy efficient
like the 30 centimeter long vampire
squid
that floats through the water without
motion with long and slender catching
arms extended
they're covered in tiny stiff hairs
which brush
food from the water this saves a lot of
energy
compared to actively catching food
for carnivorous fish it's much harder to
find food
since living prey is quite rare down
here
so the hunters have to get a perfect
grip on their victim on first strike
otherwise it will escape into the dark
many deep sea predators have several
sets of long and deadly teeth
like the viperfish which uses its long
fangs to trap even large prey
and swallow it whole or the frilled
shark
with its impressive set of 300 teeth
which are curved backwards to hook their
victims in their mouths
we sink further below the 3800 mark
as deep as the grave of the titanic we
are now
at abyssal depths here
life happens in slow motion preserving
every last bit of energy is crucial for
survival
everything down here hovers motionless
or swims
in a slow elegant fashion
the only time the animals living in this
zone move
fast is when they have to escape danger
like the dumbo octopod paddling with its
ear-like fins
or the grenadiers fish with its slow
eel-like tail beats
at 4 000 meters we finally reached
ground again
the abyssal plain it's covered in grey
mud and rocks
dusted with the remains of marine snow
which is consumed by animals like sea
cucumbers
shrimp sea urchins and seaworms
in some regions of the seafloor small
dark mineral deposits can be seen
these are manganese nodules
deep sea corals and sponges use them to
anchor themselves on the bottom of the
sea
though life is sparse on the deep sea
floor even down here there are oases
in the rift valleys where tectonic
plates are splitting apart
magma heats up seawater and creates dark
jets of water and minerals as hot as 400
degrees celsius
that form elaborate chimneys and towers
extremophile bacteria use the minerals
to create organic substances
that are the basis for unique ecosystems
as we descend further we reach the
deepest point of the abyssal plane
at six thousand meters for most of the
c4
this is as deep as it gets but if we
want to get to the deepest point of the
oceans
we're actually only halfway there
let's enter the hail zone the underworld
of the sea
it consists of long narrow trenches that
only make up around
0.25 percent of the oceans and are among
the most
extreme environments on earth only
extremophiles exist down here
like the ethereal snailfish that holds
the record for the deepest living fish
ever seen
at around 8 000 meters we see spiky and
sharp black rocks rush by as we sink
down to more than ten thousand
until we reach the final slope a trench
inside the larger mariana trench with
gently sloping sides
that in frame a valley about 1.6
kilometers wide
this is it the deepest point the
challenger deep
11 000 meters below the surface
the water pressure here is 1086 bar
taking a swim here is like having to
balance 1800 elephants on top of you
but even here life has found a way to
thrive
next to sea cucumbers white and light
pink amphipods wiggle their way through
the water
their size is astounding while their
shallow water cousins are merely a few
centimeters long
the deep sea version can reach up to 30
centimeters
and there are other things floating
elegantly through the water
plastic bags that were found by
scientists in 2018
even the remotest place on earth is not
safe
from human influence there's nothing
left to do now
and our oxygen is running out so we
begin
our ascent
[Music]
after hours of traveling through dark
nothingness we finally see a glimpse of
light
we arrive back at a calm surface
the oceans are so deep there is
so much of them we owe it to ourselves
and to our descendants to preserve them
as well as we can
there are still so many wondrous things
left to be discovered
so you're all tingly now and want to go
exploring
why not start off with some juicy
science you can use our friends from
brilliant as your springboard for a
knowledge deep dive
brilliant is a website that helps you
approach science in a practical way
through interactive courses and daily
problems in maths
science and computer science instead of
simply flooding you with information
you get the tools you need to untangle
complex topics by yourself
it's hands-on learning instead of chalk
and talk
plunge in and get to the bottom of
courses about things like geometry
waves and light gravitational physics
and many more
click the link in the description or
visit brilliant.org
nutshell to sign up for free and learn
more things than there are fish in the
sea
and there's an extra perk for kurzgesagt
viewers
the first 688 people to use the link get
20
off their annual membership which lets
you view all the daily problems in the
archives and
unlock every course brilliant helps you
end your day
a little smarter go ahead and take the
plunge
do you need more vitamin c we've also
made an epic poster featuring some of
the most fascinating creatures we
encountered on our dive
it's much less work than an aquarium but
just as soothing and pretty
you